Alagó. Até domingo passado eu tava me
escondendo em roupas largas. Oi pessoal,
meu nome é Cristiane, eu tenho 41 anos.
Eu tenho há algum tempo eu já tenho
tentado emagrecer. Também sou daquelas
[música]
que tentou várias maneiras, seja sejam
as canetinhas, sejam dietas mais
restritivas, [música] que seria
impossível a manutenção dessas dietas.
Tenho problema de tireoide é há muito
tempo, não consigo controlar, [música] é
sempre cabelo caindo, unha fraca, frio,
dificuldade de emagrecer. Passei minha
vida inteira lutando contra a balança,
sou obesa, sou bariátrica, engordei
[música] novamente, não tenho vesícula,
não tenho pêntice, enfim, muitos
problemas de saúde relacionado à questão
da obesidade. E foi quando eu comecei
essa luta, foi aonde eu entrei no efeito
sanfona, porque eu fazia vários tipos de
dieta, emagrecia, ficava bem, recebia
vários elogios porque tava magra. E aí
depois que eu terminava as benditas
[música] dietas, eu acabava entrando de
novo no ganho de peso, julgamento das
pessoas, até mesmo do meu marido, porque
sempre ficava feliz com a perda de peso
e depois sempre ficava muito triste
falando que eu não fechava a boca, que
eu devia fechar a boca, mesmo praticando
atividade física, eu não consegui
emagrecer. que a gente vai nos [música]
médicos, paga, gasta com exames e para
falar que não tem nada para falar que os
exames tão ótimos, sendo que a gente tá
com os sintomas aí. Eu mesmo tenho
sintomas [música]
de a sensação que minha língua tá
grande, as marcas dos dentes, sabe, na
minha língua e [música] tem todos os
sintomas de tireoide, de fígado ruim e
[música] descobri agora, né, na
participando do desafio. Eu sou Helena
de Porto Alegre, tenho 60 anos, a
barriga mais estendida, às vezes ficava
o rosto bem mais inchado, os braços.
>> Foram muitos anos lutando contra a
balança.
>> Sou uma mulher de 47 anos, iniciei a
menopausa com 42. Faz 5 anos que eu
estou lutando contra problemas de saúde
e ganha de peso. Já tentei nesse tipo de
situações. Já fui p sem pique, fiquei um
ano, consegui emagrecer 8 kg, mas depois
quando platou e quando eu parei de
tomar, engordei tudo de novo. Eu não
consigo emagrecer nada,
nada, nem 500 g faz mais de um ano,
tentando tudo que eu que posso. Eu
iniciei totalmente desmotivada,
desacreditada, mas falei: "Vamos lá,
mais uma tentativa". Tudo, tudo, quase
tudo ali dei o cheque. É colesterol,
cortisol
e tireoide, insulina. É, eu não durmo,
eu tô com a pneia do sono, eu não tô
deixando nem meu marido dormir. Então
assim, tá um estrago. E eu vou, eu
choro, eu já chorei. Eu já fui em vários
endocrinologistas aqui na Suíça, eu já
chorei com histório.
>> Há seis dias atrás eu pesava 72,5
e hoje eu tô pesando 69,7.
E nessa semana isso foi possível.
Consegui ver que é que é é tudo isso é
possível. O emagrecimento ele é
possível, você não passa fome.
>> Quero dizer que eu perdi 3 kg, que essa
semana tem sido uma semana assim de
muita aprendizagem.
Aprendi que não existe uma uma dieta
100%, que nós temos que fazer a
ciclagem, mas é muito importante que nós
tenhamos também um acompanhamento de um
profissional verdadeiro.
>> Perdi 5 kg nessa semana do jejum. Tive
ótimos resultados no desafio. Perdi
cintura, perdi quadril, perdi peso.
>> E agora em
7 dias consegui eliminar 5,g300.
Participar desse desafio foi um uma luz
na no fim do túnel. Hoje eu saí de casa
do jeito que eu gosto de sair, que é
de barriguinha de fora, apesar dos meus
50 anos de idade. E antes eu vestia
essas roupas e ficava aquela banha
caindo. Consegui eliminar 3, kg. Eu
consegui emagrecer 2, kg.
>> E eu não acreditei quando eu vi que eu
consegui eliminar 2,1.
E assim, é um avanço muito grande. É
muito grande. E medidas, 2 cm de medidas
de tudo.
>> Eu eliminei 3,700
e 2 cm de de cintura e três de de
quadril, né, de de circunferência. Mas o
o importante para mim foi sentir que eu
sabe que eu posso, que eu consigo. Olha
só, hoje eu me olho no espelho e já vejo
o meu pescoço, ele tava um pouco mais
largo, sabe? A a a cintura tava mais
estufadinha, tinha mais pneuzinho. Muito
feliz. Eu eliminei 5,2. Cara, eu mudei
assim como se fosse da água pro vinho,
de verdade. Eu tô muito feliz, Dr.
Renan.
>> Bom dia, bom dia, bom dia, bom dia,
meninas. Sejam muito bem-vindas à nossa
quinta aula, gente. Gente, como que faz,
né? Qu sexta-feira voou. Sejam muito
bem-vindas à nossa quinta aula do
Desafio do jejum. E essa é uma das aulas
mais especiais, porque a gente começa a
trabalhar a mentalidade de vocês, porque
assim, vocês acabaram de ver, né, essas
alunas que passaram por aqui em algum
momento, e elas falam uma coisa: "Ok,
perdi medidas, mas agora eu tenho uma
visão diferente sobre a minha saúde, eu
tô com mais exposição, tô me sentindo
melhor, tô me sentindo com mais
vitalidade". a família começa a perceber
principalmente no humor, porque não
adianta eu falar com vocês sobre base
hormonabólica, não adianta eu falar com
vocês sobre metabolismo, não adianta eu
falar com vocês tudo sobre dieta, sobre
ciclagens, se
você não tem uma mentalidade de
crescimento, de evolução, e se você não
consegue se libertar dessas amarras
invisíveis que vocês têm. Portanto,
meninas, portanto, sejam muito
bem-vindas. E eu quero falar uma coisa
para vocês. Amanhã, sábado, é o dia da
pesagem de vocês. Então, quero todo
mundo, ó, todo mundo aqui. Amanhã é o
dia da pesagem de vocês.
Temos um acordo, combinados? Porque eu
quero que amanhã vocês venham me contar
o quanto que vocês estão pesando. Claro
que é porque para vocês participarem do
concurso que a gente vai liberar para
você, vou falar mais no final da nossa
aula de hoje sobre o concurso. Vocês
precisam se pesar amanhã, viu, meninas?
Entendidos? Só pra gente já deixar tudo
alinhado para que ninguém perca essa
informação. [roncando] Ansiosas. Mas
vamos lá. Hoje tem muita coisa porque é
uma das aulas que eu mais gosto de
fazer, uma das aulas mais especiais,
porque a gente precisa começar a se
libertar dessas amas invisíveis. Lembra
que eu falei da mochila ontem com vocês?
Mas antes, meninas, entenda uma coisa.
Nesse desafio, eu tô te ajudando a
entender o caminho para você continuar
emagrecendo, né? Então essa semana,
esses sete dias, eles são um reset do
seu metabolismo e mais do que resete, é
uma absorção de conhecimento,
conhecimento sobre você.
E eu vou te ensinar estratégias para que
você continue emagrecendo todos os
quilos que você quiser. E as minhas
alunas conseguem emagrecer até 20 kg em
45 dias, de forma natural, definitiva, e
continuar emagrecendo. E mais do que
isso, a manutenção. E isso é construído
a partir de toda essa base de
conhecimento que vocês tiveram nessa
semana. Porque lá na aula um, eu te
mostrei o que na aula um, os cinco erros
que te impedem de emagrecer. E você vive
continuando repetindo esses erros. Eu te
entreguei a primeira chave secreta,
lembra do mapa? Te ensinei a olhar sua
pontuação. Então, te entreguei o mapa do
emagrecimento. Esse mapa do
emagrecimento trouxe uma clareza sobre a
sua saúde que você não tinha
e que é o básico, você acostumou se
sentir mal. E ficou muito claro o perfil
hormonal que você tem. Não é porque a
sua pontuação é relativamente baixa,
abaixo de 10, que você tem uma saúde
plena, que você tem uma saúde excelente,
porque se você tiver um único problema
metabólico, ele é suficiente para
impedir o seu emagrecimento.
Na aula dois, eu te mostrei os pilares
do emagrecimento definitivo, mente, base
hormonal metabólica e alimentação. e te
entreguei a segunda chave secreta, que
foi nosso radar de problemas, onde você
teve um um uma fotografia visual do seus
problemas hormonais e quanto mais para
fora assinalado naquele radar, piora o
seu problema de saúde e você descobriu
quais os hormônios alterados, porque eu
revelei a relação de cada hormônio com o
seu mapa do emagrecimento.
Na nossa terceira aula, eu fiz uma
análise e te ensinei tudo sobre a tríade
hormonal da obesidade, tireoide,
insulina, cortisol.
E te entreguei a terceira chave secreta,
que foi o nosso e-book de base
hormonabólica, que foi esse e-book com
tudo que eu falei na aula para vocês. Na
nossa quarta aula que aconteceu ontem,
falamos sobre o eixo sono intestino,
pilar, o segundo pilar, ciclagem de
dietas e te entreguei a quarta chave
secreta, o e-book de intestino, sono,
ciclagens, dietas. E o que que te
aguarda nessa nossa quinta aula? Hoje a
gente começa a fazer um detox mental.
[roncando] Porque não adianta eu te
passar a melhor estratégia, a melhor
ciclagem, se você é uma pessoa que ainda
acha que os conceitos sobre
emagrecimento, sobre saúde que você
aplicou na sua vida inteira ainda são
certos. Ainda é a forma correta de você
de você conseguir perder peso. Só que
você possui amarras invisíveis. amarras
como culpa, medo, não merecimento. E
essas amarras puxam várias outras
amarras. E a gente precisa começar a
eliminar essas amarras hoje. E eu
preciso e como que a gente começa a
eliminar? Enxergando. Claro que não é de
uma, de uma hora para outra, mas a
partir do momento que você tem
consciência do problema, fica muito mais
fácil de identificar quando ele aparece.
E aí você vai ser um um policial da sua
vida. você, ó, apareceu essa sensação
aqui, opa,
acorda. E você tenta quebrar esse
padrão. Mas primeiro eu quero agradecer
vocês pela nossa aula de ontem, pelas
nossas milhares de visualizações. Isso
mostra o comprometimento, a entrega de
vocês. Lembra que eu [roncando] pedi lá
no começo da semana, eu quero que vocês
se priorizem, se colocam prioridade
nessa semana e vocês estão aqui
cumprindo o que a gente falou, cumprindo
o que eu pedi para vocês. E aqui, ó,
milhares de comentários do nosso post da
aula de ontem do #eu meamo. Gente, olha
o poder disso. Olha o poder disso. Você
falar para você que você se ama. Quando
foi a última vez que você falou que se
ama?
Quando foi a última vez que você falou
para você e escreveu: "Eu me amo",
hein? Quando foi? Você nem sabe quando.
Talvez você nunca falou isso.
E aqui foram milhares de de mensagens de
vocês. Eu quero agradecer o carinho e
vocês. Eu me amo, Dr. Renan, cada dia
mais encantada com cada detalhe das
aulas. [roncando]
Tudo que nós estamos aprendendo,
aprendendo sobre a gente. O jejum. Tem
gente falou: "Olha, ó, o jejum tá sendo
tranquilo, mas o mais incrível é
aprender sobre os meus hormônios, sobre
a minha saúde, olhar para mim de uma
forma que eu nunca tinha olhado".
E eu sei que surgem dúvidas sobre jejum.
Claro que a gente tá falando muito sobre
jejum aqui nos últimos dias, mas eu tô
falando muito mais sobre você do que
sobre jejum. Então, uma dúvida que
surgiu, esse jejum ele é só para 7 dias?
Sim, vocês entraram aqui sabendo, ele é
um desafio de 7 dias, ele foi desenhado
para 7 dias. Então, você não pode
continuar com essa mesma estratégia
semana que vem, porque lembro que vocês
aprenderam ontem sobre ciclagem de
dietas. Eu preciso trocar de dieta,
preciso trocar de estratégia. Então,
hoje vocês vão fazer o segundo jejum de
18 horas, amanhã vocês vão bater 20
horas de jejum. E aí uma dúvida, né, Dr.
Ra, mas jejum prolongado não vai me
causar uma gastrite? Claro que não. Se
você fica hora sem se alimentar, você
protege seu estômago. Mas se você tiver
gastrite, sentir qualquer coisa,
chazinho de espinheira santa, chazinho
de hortelã, fantástico para estômago.
Mas tô rindo, não. Jejum para mulher 40
mais, 50 mais, 60 mais, isso muda. Tem
algum horário que é melhor? Não. O que
importa é a janela de período que você
fica sem se alimentar com o quê? a
janela do período que você fica sem se
alimentar com a alimentação que você faz
no período que você se alimenta.
Proteína da forma correta, carboidrato
da forma correta, tem estratégia de mais
prolongado que a gente controla o
consumo de carboidrato.
E uma outra dúvida que surgiu muito, Dr.
Renão, jejum vai piorar minha tireoide?
Gente, isso não existe, tá? Jejum não
piora tireoide, muito pelo contrário.
Com o jejum melhoro função de fígado que
melhora a conversão dos hormãos
tiroidianos. E eu sei que vocês ficam
preocupados com a pontuação do mapa,
porque teve muita gente aqui que tá na
no perfil hormonal da prisioneira e essa
pontuação do mapa alta, sabia que sua
saúde tava ruim, você já sabia. Isso não
é nenhuma surpresa, né? Mas agora a
gente começou a tratar, é um primeiro
passo. Essa semana é um reset do seu
metabolismo. Vocês estão no primeiro
degrau do tratamento para conquistar o
emagrecimento definitivo. E amanhã vocês
farão o nosso quinto dia, o jejum de 20
horas. O que que acontece no seu corpo
no jejum de 20 horas? Primeiro, insulina
cai. E você já aprendeu que quando a
insulina cai, a gente cria esse ambiente
perfeito para quê? Para queima de
gordura. [roncando] Aí você vai ativar
ainda mais a queima de gordura. O seu
corpo começa a potencializar a troca de
células velhas por células novas.
E se você tiver algum mal-estar, olha,
Dr. Hernan, senti algum mal-estar, uma
tonturinha, quebra o jejum antes, não
tem problema. Mas eu sei que vocês vão
conseguir. Um segredo desse desse jejum
de 20 horas é muita água no período de
jejum. Pode consumir água com gás se
tiver com fome, porque ele vai dilatar o
estômago. E outra coisa muito legal, o
psílium. Você pode utilizar o psíum,
você pode utilizar glucobanano. E nesse
jejum de 20 horas, quando passar de 16
horas, se você quiser, não é
obrigatório, você pode colocar alguma
fonte de gordura, uma colherzinha de
óleo de coco no café ou uma colherzinha
de azeite ou uma colherzinha de manteiga
gui. Não pode ser manteiga normal, tem
que ser manteiga gui, porque a manteiga
normal vai ter o carboidrato ali do do
derivado do leite. A manteiga gui pela
clarificação, é retirado.
OK? Então você pode consumir uma
fontezinha de gordura se quiser, porque
isso vai te dar saciedade, mas não é
obrigatório você consumir. Não é
obrigatório você consumir. Entendido?
OK.
Perfeito, meninas. E não se esqueçam, tá
tendo dor de cabeça, tá tendo algum
malstar, sensação de fraqueza, a pitada
de sal na água. Três copos de água que
você toma em jejum, coloca pitadinha de
sal. Isso vai trazer um bem-estar.
Porque nesse tipo de jejum prolongado,
eu melhor, começo a melhorar o sistema
fígado, pâncreas e o intestino. E isso
faz parte de um detox. Fígado, pâncreas,
intestino vai fazer parte dessa
detoxificação que a gente busca.
Então, quero que vocês prestem atenção.
Jejum amanhã de 20 horas. O meu horário
preferido é, eu faço a minha, quando eu
vou fazer um jejum prolongado de 20
horas, eu faço minha última refeição do
dia, umas 5 da tarde,
4, 5 da tarde, refeição melhor e aí eu
vou almoçar no outro dia próximo de 1 da
tarde. Faço isso. É o meu horário
preferido, mas você pode fazer da forma
que você quiser. Eu quero mostrar agora,
meninas, porque muitas de vocês estão
assim: "Doutor Renan, mas eu tô cheio de
problema de saúde, minha pontuação do
mapa tá alta, eu não sei o que fazer".
Eu quero mostrar um vídeo aqui para
vocês rapidinho da história da Cris. A
Cris é um caso clássico da mulher que
tentou de tudo e tinha todos os
problemas hormonais. Todos. Todos os
problemas hormonais.
Todos.
E chegou a ser desacreditada por médico,
pela família dela, assim como muita de
vocês.
E ela teve um resultado surreal. Olha
isso daqui.
>> 6 anos. Eu tô na menopausa já desde os
53. Eu tô na luta do emagrecimento desde
os 11 anos de idade, acredite. Naquela
época, inclusive, eu cheguei aí em
médico para emagrecer e tomei um remédio
que chamava Inibex, que eu nem sei se
existe ainda hoje em dia.
>> De lá para cá, acabei descobrindo que eu
tinha o hipotiroidismo.
Aí comecei a tomar o Centro, vinha
tomando cintroide, toma até hoje. Mas eu
sempre fui engordando, fazia dieta,
emagrecia, engordava de novo, tomava
remédio, tomava fé em proporex.
Sibutramina, todos os remédios
conhecidos, até o Zempi que eu cheguei a
usar, a foi o último remédio que eu
tomei. Só que assim, os medicamentos
para emagrecer me davam, me deixavam
muito nervosa. Eu a ponto assim de um
dia eu joguei um notebook em cima de uma
mesa de vidro por causa de uma
brincadeira que meu filho e meu marido
fizeram comigo. Aí eles chegaram, me
chamaram de lado e falaram assim: "Olha,
por favor, não toma mais remédio para
emagrecer". E aí de lá para cá eu não
tomei mais o remédio para emagrecer e
cheguei nos 118,400g,
que era o que eu tinha quando eu comecei
a fazer o o pé. A última vez que eu fui
no médico, ele virou e falou assim para
mim: "Bom, é o seguinte. Você tá muito
gordo, eu já falei para você que você
precisa emagrecer, você não emagrece, eu
vou te dar um ultimato. Ou você faz uma
bariátrica porque senão daqui alguns,
algum tempinho você não vai mais andar,
porque a sua perna incha, você me fala
que você tem dor." E eu com essa
história de menopausa, eu tinha dor cada
dia num lugar. Um dia eu acordava com
dor na sola do pé, no outro dia eu
acordava com dor na lombar, joelho,
cervical. É uma dor que andava pelo meu
corpo. Como eu não queria fazer a
bariátrica, eu falei: "Eu tenho que
tomar uma atitude, então eu tenho que
mexer com a minha cabeça, eu tenho que
me comprometer comigo, eu tenho que me
olhar no espelho e falar: "Cris, eu
gosto de você". A hora que ele falou
aquilo, eu falei: "Pronto, foi a gota
d'água". Ele tem razão. Eu preciso me
tratar para eu não deixar os outros
sofrendo depois ou para eu não dar
trabalho pros outros além de eu sofrer.
Claro que foi o que eu resolvi. As
minhas dores foram sumindo assim como do
nada. Era uma coisa impressionante como
tudo foi melhorando até que chegou o 45º
dia do do do tratamento, né, o dia de
pesar. Eu falei: "Ai, será que eu
emagreci mesmo, né? Tem aquela dúvida,
né? Eu que nem eu falei, a gente a gente
não acredita na gente mais, né? Aí
quando eu me pesei, vi que eu tinha
emagrecido de 13 para 14 kg, eu falei:
"Nossa, eu emagreci". E eu tinha falado
para mim mesmo. Eu falei: "Se eu
emagrecer até 10 kg, eu vou continuar
para chegar onde eu quero, né?" E aí
quando eu vi que tava nos 14, 13, 14 kg,
ah, foi felicidade.
>> Quanto, quantos quilos ao todo, Cris?
>> 33. 33 kg eliminados, sendo 13 em 45
dias.
>> Olha essa transformação, Cris.
>> É, é um conjunto, né? Assim, a gente faz
a análise inicial, eh, descobre os
problemas que que tavam atrapalhando a
resistência insulínica. Eu, assim, eu
não me eu nem me alimentava assim tão
mal. O jeito como o senhor abraça a
gente, como você, eu vou tentar
conseguir, como você abraça a gente. É
assim, é incrível, sabe? Eu sou sua fã
assim de carteirinha, né?
>> Olha, Cris, obrigado, né? Por toda a
confiança.
>> Olha isso, né, meninas? Então, assim, a
sua família sofre junto, tá?
A sua família tá ali percebendo tudo que
tá acontecendo com você, só que você
acha que ninguém tá nem reparando o que
que você tá fazendo. Só que as pessoas
já começam a ficar quietas até que chega
um momento que não dá mais, né?
Então,
[limpando a garganta] então quando você
vê a história da Cris, 56 anos de idade,
pós-menopausa,
gordura no fígado, obesidade, grau três,
eh, pré-diabetes, tireóides regulado,
ela tinha todos os problemas hormonais,
perdeu 13 kg em 45 dias e ao todo 33 kg,
como aluna PEF 360.
[roncando] Não é só dieta. Isso daqui é
mudança de um comportamento de
mentalidade, porque ela já tava tentando
se aceitar de um jeito que ela não era
feliz. Quantas aqui já falaram: "Ah, vou
me aceitar". Mas você se aceita de
verdade assim? Você se aceita?
Porque a gente tá aqui, a gente tem que
ser feliz, sabe?
A gente tem que ser feliz.
Tem alguém que falou aqui, você lê mesmo
os nossos comentários?
De vez em quando sim, porque eu tenho
que fechar aqui para focar na aula para
vocês. Às vezes eu fecho os fecho os
comentários, viu, gente? [risadas]
Então, muitas de vocês não se aceitam,
né?
[roncando]
Não é para se aceitar
do jeito que você não é feliz. Então,
pra gente começar a quebrar esses
padrões, eu preciso começar a construir
um detox da mente para você. E hoje eu
vou te entregar o plano perfeito do seu
emagrecimento. Eu vou montar esse plano
perfeito na sua frente hoje. Mas
primeiro eu quero que você entenda isso
aqui. Eu te enxergo, sabia? Eu te vejo.
Eu sei que quando você fala que você faz
dieta, eu sei que você faz. Eu sei
quando você fala que come pouco, eu sei
que você faz. Eu sei que você come
pouco, eu sei que você tenta, eu vejo
isso. O contrário do de muitos
profissionais que vocês vão, como o caso
da Cris, você vai lá, faz dieta, toma
seu remédio, faz tudo e você não
emagrece, ele vai falar que a culpa é
sua. Ah, a culpa é sua, aposta que você
tá comendo escondido. Ah, existem
calorias,
calorias escondidas na sua dieta. Ou
você não quer me contar a verdade, ou
não tomou remédio. Enfim, inúmeras
desculpas que jogam o peso e a culpa
sobre você. Mas eu acredito quando você
fala que faz dieta. E você também
entendeu nessa semana que você não tem
culpa de vários problemas hormonais que
aconteceram com você. Então acontecem
muitos desafios. Você tem medo. Por que
que você tem medo? Por conta de traumas.
Toda vez que você tenta emagrecer e tem
reganho de peso, seu cérebro instala
instala uma camada do trauma. Opa, me
senti machucado aqui quando eu tive
reanho de peso. Então agora eu sei que
quando eu vou fazer dieta, eu posso
sofrer. Por isso que você começa a ver a
dieta como sofrimento. É a mesma coisa.
Você tá andando numa trilha e vê uma
cobra cascavel, você vai ficar com medo,
vai gritar, vai correr. Por quê? Por que
que você tem medo daquilo? Porque o seu
cérebro a gente tá lou informação que
aquilo é risco de vida. A mesma coisa.
Você toda vez teve regimes peso, sofreu,
o seu cérebro, ele vai criar uma
armadura em você para você nunca mais
chegar perto daquilo. E quando você
começa a chegar perto daquilo, você
começa a se sabotar.
Você começa a tentar se sabotar.
Mas teve muitas vezes que você escolheu
desistir. A gente precisa ser muito
claro. Nós somos adultos aqui. A maioria
das vezes você não teve culpa, mas teve
vezes que você escolheu se abandonar
também.
E você vive tentando achar o culpado, só
que você tá tão cega que você não
entende que você é a pessoa que se sente
culpado o tempo todo, porque você é uma
pessoa que quer sempre fazer mais pelo
outro.
E a mulher foi ensinada, escuta o que eu
tô falando, a mulher foi ensinada que
uma boa mãe é a que faz mais pelos seus
filhos, uma boa esposa é a que faz mais
pelo marido, uma boa filha é a que faz
mais pelos seus pais, uma boa pessoa,
uma bo bom funcionário é a que faz mais
por todo mundo ali na empresa
em afetando a sua própria saúde,
independente do estado de saúde
emocional que você tá. Então você foi
ensinado a ser esse tipo de mulher e
quando você não é, você sente culpada.
Por exemplo, a semana você tá se
priorizando aqui comigo,
você poderia estar priorizando outra
coisa. Quem é que não teve esse tipo de
pensamento?
Por quê? Porque essa culpa interna que
existe em você. Só que eu já começo a
perceber uma nova consciência em vocês
aqui.
Começo a perceber uma nova consciência
em vocês. Porque a gente precisa
entender sobre essa mochila das amarras
invisíveis.
Você não precisa carregar tudo isso. E
quando eu trago todos esses sintomas
dessa mochila, das amarras invisíveis,
traumas, sensações, medos, autoabandono,
autossabotagem, falta de tempo,
tristeza, falta de alegria,
desanimada, você não sente merecedora,
não sente capaz. Eu não preciso entrar
com tratamento para cuidar cada um
desses dessas amarras. Talvez tirando
uma amarra, eu já elimino várias dessas
amarras aqui,
porque existem três nós principais
dessas amarras invisíveis que a gente
precisa desatar. E desatando esses três
nós, todo o resto vai embora. Então hoje
eu quero que você grave isso que eu vou
te ensinar tudo. Culpa, medo e
indignidade.
Você não sente digna.
Vamos aprender a culpa. Quem aqui se
sente culpada? Talvez você não consegue
enxergar isso porque é ela é invisível,
sabe? Você acha que é uma fraqueza, você
acha que é sua personalidade fazer mais
pelos outros, você acha que você é
assim: "Ah, eu sou uma pessoa muito boa,
eu faço mais por todo mundo." Na
verdade, não é, você só tá viciada. E aí
é um problema, né? Porque a culpa ela
não é uma fraqueza, ela é o vício mais
perigoso que existe.
[roncando][limpando a garganta] Porque a
culpa que eu vou falar aqui não é a
culpa que você tem na sua cabeça. Porque
qual que é a culpa que existe na sua
cabeça? A culpa de quando você fez
alguma coisa errada. Não. A culpa que
você tem aqui, ela é muito mais
profunda, porque é uma culpa que faz
parte de quem você é. É a culpa de que
se você fizer por você,
você está deixando de doar energia para
fazer pro outro. E quando você começa a
fazer alguma coisa por você, o que que
acontece? Vem a culpa. E você não sabe
porquê dessa culpa.
Pensa comigo aqui. Vamos lá. Quando você
para para tomar um café,
antes de você levar a xícara na boca,
você já tá pensando no que que vai fazer
no vai fazer ao longo do dia.
Você já tá pensando na comida que você
vai preparar, já tá pensando no
trabalho, já tá pensando no filho, no
marido, nos seus pais, gente, porque
café não tem gosto mais. Vamos lá, você
vai comprar uma roupa para você, na hora
de você pagar, não vem aquela vozinha
que fala assim: "Olha só, será que eu
preciso disso mesmo aqui?
Esse dinheiro não vai fazer falta paraos
meus filhos. Nossa, podia comprar um
presentinho pro meu neto. Aí você começa
a comprar presentinho paraas pessoas e
você quem quem que presenteia você?
Aí de repente você deita à tarde para
dar uma descansadinha e vem a lista:
"Nossa, a louça tá suja, tem que
preparar o almoço, tem que ir no
mercado, tem que fazer isso, tem que
fazer uma ligação paraa minha mãe para
ver como que ela tá". Você não consegue,
percebe que você não consegue fazer nada
por você sem ficar pedindo desculpa o
tempo todo. Você deitou um pouco, você
já tá se sentindo culpada porque você
não tá fazendo o resto.
Como se cada minuto da sua vida
pertencesse a outra pessoa.
Sabe o que que você virou no final das
contas? Você virou uma torneirinha que
pinga, pinga, pinga e aquela torneirinha
fica gotejando. Sabe aquela goteirinha
fica gotejando
e ninguém vê, mas em algum momento esse
tanque aí, ó, ele vai esvaziar. A casa
inteira bebe dessa goteirinha aí, ó. sua
família, seus filhos, seu trabalho, seus
pais, você tá entregando para todo
mundo, mas só que chega um momento que
acaba a água desse desse tanque aí. E
aí,
e aí é o momento que surgem doenças, uma
depressão, ansiedade, um vazio interno,
você ganha peso e você tem que preencher
esse vazio com quê? Você preenche com
comida. Você não consegue fazer um prato
e comer com calma por você mesmo.
Aí vem aquela culpa invisível. Nossa,
tem gente precisando de você. Você tem
que fazer isso, tem que fazer aquilo.
Você é a última a servir comida para
você na sua casa.
E essa culpa, ela é viciante. Sabe por
quê que ela é viciante?
Porque
no meio da dessa culpa vem um alívio.
Então você tá lá querendo fazer alguma
coisa para você. de repente você sente
culpado e começa a fazer mais pelos
outros.
Essa culpa traz um alívio. Porque a
pessoa que se sente culpada, escuta o
que eu vou falar agora, a pessoa que se
sente culpada,
[roncando]
ela entende que a responsabilidade é
dela também de mudar. A pessoa que tem
culpa, ela é diferente da pessoa que é
vítima. A pessoa que é vítima, a culpa é
sempre do outro. Quem tá no vitimismo, a
culpa é sempre do outro. Então, a
responsabilidade da mudança é do outro,
já que a culpa é do outro. Agora, a
pessoa que tem essa culpa interna
tem um alívio. Por quê? Um alívio
viciante, porque no fundo ela sabe, ah,
em qualquer momento eu faço por mim,
porque a responsabilidade é minha mesmo.
Você sente responsável pela sua mudança?
Você sente culpada pela sua mudança?
Então você tá viciada nisso. Só que esse
vício ele foi instalado porque você
aprendeu
que
mulher boa é a que faz mais pelo outro,
esposa boa que faz mais pelo marido, mãe
boa que faz mais pelos filhos, filho
bom, filha boa é a que faz mais pelos
pais. Você aprendeu a ser assim, porque
quando criança você absorve todo esse
esse o cérebro da criança é igual uma
esponja.
E você aprende com padrões de repetição,
você aprende com o que falam para você,
você aprende quando te comparam com
alguém.
E aí você fica o dia inteiro num
tribunal aí se defendendo
de só querer se cuidar, de só querer
comprar uma roupa para você, de só
querer sentar com calma, sem ninguém te
encher no saco.
Só que seu corpo vai cobrar. Ele vai
cobrar
em doenças, em sintomas,
vai ter o reflexo de alguma forma.
Então, hoje eu quero te falar uma coisa.
Você tem a permissão de fazer por você,
mas você tem que querer isso, porque não
adianta eu te ensinar tudo e você não
querer por você.
Sempre vão ter 1000 coisas acontecendo
na sua vida. E se essas 1000 coisas
forem prioridade,
a culpa
ainda te domina. E no dia que você solta
essa culpa, vários problemas daquela
mochila que você carrega a vida inteira
vão embora.
Então você não precisa sofrer para
merecer, você não precisa sofrer para
fazer por você, você não precisa se
sentir esgotada para ter valor.
Então cuida de você, sabe?
E você se culpa por tudo, né? Ai comeu
que não devia, culpa é sua. Foi pra
academia, não foi pra academia, falha
sua. Dieta não funcionou, eu que não me
esforcei bastante. Ganhou peso de volta,
ah, eu que sou fraca, sempre fui. Não é
assim.
>> [roncando]
>> Grava isso aqui. Culpa não é fraqueza.
Culpa não é fraqueza. é o vício mais
perigoso que existe.
E novamente, quando você se sente
culpado, você entende que a
responsabilidade é sua. E a hora que
você percebe, ah, segunda-feira que vem
eu começo,
você trouxe esse alívio para essa culpa
imediata imediatamente.
O problema é que soltar a culpa dá mais
medo do que segurar, porque você criou
essa identidade sua. Eu sou assim, eu
sou essa mulher, eu me comporto desse
jeito. E se você solta essa culpa, você
acha que você vai perder sua identidade,
a boazinha, a mulher boazinha que você
é, não. Você só precisa ter um
equilíbrio entregar e receber.
E o dia que você solta a culpa, vários
desses sintomas começam a morrer.
Vergonha, o que há de errado comigo,
autossabotagem, compulsão pós culpa.
Você começa a matar vários sintomas
dessa mochila de amarras invisíveis.
E aí vem o medo, né?
O medo é um problema, porque o medo, eu
não tô falando esse medo, ah, eu tenho
medo da cobra cascavel, tenho medo de
morrer, tenho medo de perder minha, não.
Tô falando de um medo diferente.
É um medo que ele te engana, ele é
disfarçado de proteção.
Entenda uma coisa, ter medo de
assombração, ter medo de alguma coisa,
ter medo, enfim, é diferente desse medo
que a gente tá falando aqui. Eu tô
falando de um medo que ele parece que é
proteção,
sabe? Então assim,
e aqui que tá uma armadilha que você às
vezes não consegue perceber.
Entenda uma coisa,
louça boa, vamos falar aparelho de
jantar, você ganha aquele aparelho de
jantar, de casamento, ou você recebeu da
sua mãe, herdou da sua mãe, herdou da
sua família. Lindo aparelho de jantar,
mas ele fica lá guardado. Louça, taça de
cristal, toalha bordada. E aí vem um um
enxoval que sua mãe deixou para você.
Onde que isso fica? Na sua casa fica lá
guardado. Lá no fundo do armário. Você
guarda, coloca até no jornal, tudo
bonitinho, não deixa ninguém encostar.
Parece aquilo ali é um tesouro, né? Uma
herança que você tem. Você protege
tanto, tanto que é bom porque você tem
medo de quebrar. É, você passar a vida
inteira comendo em prato lascado, copo
lascado e você tinha lá a louça linda
para você usar. [roncando]
A louça boa, escuta o que eu tô falando,
a louça boa, ela vai morrer intacta,
sem nunca ter usado
e sem perceber. Você faz isso com você
mesmo.
Você acha que você desiste dieta. Sabe
por quê? por preguiça, por falta de
vontade, mas não é não. Você já tentou
muitas vezes dieta e todas as vezes que
você tentou, você fracassou. Então
imagina assim, se você tenta uma coisa e
fracassa, é como se você caísse no chão,
como se você quebrasse. É a mesma coisa
da louça. Você não quer usar essa louça
porque você tem medo dela quebrar.
E aí você aprende que
cair, escuta o que eu vou falar agora,
cair toda vez que você tem o regio de
peso, a frustração ou quando você pega
essa louça e ela quebra, dói. Então cair
dói mais
do que você tentar subir.
Grava isso. Você colocou no seu cérebro
a informação de que cair dói muito mais
do que tentar subir. E aí você tenta se
aceitar, falou: "Olha, eu vou, não vou
tentar de novo, porque você começa a
arrumar mil desculpas,
mil desculpas que te fazem desistir
antes de tentar. Ah, para que que eu vou
tentar? Já passei da menopausa, já
passei dos 40, dos 50, dos 60. Ah, já
tentei tanta coisa, deu errado. Para que
eu vou tentar de novo?"
Aí você começa a ter preguiça. A
preguiça ela não é a covardia, não. A
preguiça acontece pelo medo de cair de
novo. Então você não se permite tentar
e daí por conta desse medo você cria uma
armadura e você vira vira uma
prisioneira dessa armadura. É por isso
que quando chegam as alunas para mim:
"Nossa, doutor, eu tô com medo, tô
insegura, será que vai dar certo para
mim? Será que não vai?"
Isso é seu corpo se defendendo do medo
de cair, porque você sabe que se der
errado dói muito mais do que você tentar
subir.
Só que o seu medo te paralisa, né? E aí
você cansa. Só que não vem só o medo,
não vem só a estagnação. O que que vem
de problema de doença de de problemas
hormonais metabólicos,
pressão alta? Uma glicose,
câncer, doenças autoimunes se você não
mudar?
Então, entenda uma coisa, você ter
coragem não é falta de medo, tá? Coragem
é você ter coragem de tirar aquela louça
lá que você ganhou da sua família, seu
enxoval e usar mesmo sabendo,
mesmo sabendo que pode ter o mínimo
risco,
porque sair da zona de conforto dá medo
mesmo, mas a coragem é sair da zona de
conforto mesmo com medo.
Aí você desiste antes de tentar.
Ah, segundo eu começo, começa empolgada,
né? Em terceiro dia abandona. Ai, sente
uma preguiça estranha. Essa preguiça
[risadas] estranha é que, ó, seu
inconsciente te corrédia.
Ah, para que tentar de novo? Dá sempre
errado.
Isso não é medo de falhar, é só medo de
não conseguir. É, é só medo de conseguir
e cair, porque você tem medo de quebrar,
porque dói mais do que tentar subir.
Grava isso. Não esquece isso. O medo é
apenas um comportamento que o seu
inconsciente tá impondo sobre você
devido a traumas que você teve no
passado.
E quando o medo cai, você para de fugir.
Aí cai, acaba a procrastinação.
Por que que você deixa tudo para depois?
Por que que você procrastina se cuidar?
Porque se porque hoje você acredita que
você não merece, que você não é capaz,
que você é culpada, que você tem que
fazer mais pelos outros.
E se você fizer e der certo, se você
fizer e der certo, você vai quebrar toda
aquela identidade que você montou sobre
você.
Mas e se você fizer e der errado, você
confirma que você não é capaz. Por isso
que você estagna.
Tanto se der certo quanto se der errado,
quem tá nesse modo mental,
você acha que vai sentir algum tipo de
dor.
E aí vem indignidade, né?
E aí vem dignidade.
Porque eu não tô falando aqui só sobre
do campo emocional, tô falando sobre
neurociência também.
A sensação de não merecer. Você não
sente merecedora.
Você acha que você merece ser feliz?
Porque esse terceiro nó da corda, ele
ele é mais imperceptível
e às vezes você nunca ouviu falar sobre
ele.
Entenda uma coisa aqui. Uma coisa é você
falar: "Eu não mereço". Outra coisa é
você não ser digna.
Isso é muito mais pesado. [roncando]
Você tem aí, ó, uma roupa guardada aí no
seu, com certeza você tem uma roupa
guardada no seu guarda-roupa que você
quer usar, esperando você usar um dia.
Eu sei que tem, toda mulher tem, seja
uma calça jeans, seja um vestido, seja
um short, eu sei que tem uma roupa aí te
esperando.
Só que repara uma coisa, né? Repara uma
coisa. Você vai lá, compra uma roupa
bonita paraos seus filhos. Você vai lá,
compra roupa nova pro seu marido num
casamento, você vai lá, cuida dos seus
pais, leva presentinho paraa neto
e você fica para depois, né? Aí você
fala: "Ai, quando eu emagrecer, aí eu
mereço usar. Quando eu emagrecer, eu uso
o que tem de antigo lá no guarda-roupa.
Parece que você deixa sempre para depois
o seu direito de de se sentir bonita, o
direito de pertencer, o direito de doar
para você mesma.
É como se você tivesse, por exemplo, se
colocado ali, você vai numa sala de
espera de consultório, só que você fica
ali, ó, 30 anos nessa sala de espera
e quando vai alguém vai fazer alguma
coisa por você?
A gente tem que entender que ninguém vai
fazer nada pra gente se a gente não
pegar e fazer.
Se nem você se acha merecedora, por que
que as pessoas vão achar?
E sabe de onde que entenda de onde que
vem isso. A gente tem que entender a
raiz das coisas. Em algum momento da sua
vida, quando você era criança, ou alguma
frase que alguém falou para você que te
machucou, ou alguém que te comparou com
alguém, ah, mas a você deveria ser mais
como a sua mãe, você deveria ser mais
como a sua irmã. Nossa, mas a sua amiga
ela é tão comportada e você é um terror.
E vocês que são mães aqui, vocês fazem
isso com os filhos de vocês. E isso
criam amarras invisíveis que você não
tem controle sobre essa sobre essas
amarras. E aí você cresce e sem perceber
você passa uma vida inteira tentando
provar que aquela frase, que aquela
identidade que você criou sobre você é
verdadeira.
Ah, eu não sou como a minha irmã. Você
passa a vida inteira tentando provar
isso. Ah, eu não sou boa o suficiente.
Você passa a vida inteira tentando
provar isso.
Aí seus pais te chamam a vida inteira de
egoísta. Aí você passa a vida inteira
tentando provar o contrário.
Portanto, você é um padrão de
comportamento de acordo com aquilo que
instalaram no seu cérebro.
Precisa de terapia para tirar isso, viu,
gente?
>> [roncando]
>> E aí seu corpo vira como se fosse uma
dívida que você tivesse, sabe? Que que
sempre vem essa cobrança, cobrança,
cobrança, mas é uma dívida que não acaba
e você não consegue emagrecer, você não
consegue se cuidar, você se esconde
de quem você é de verdade e você cria
uma persona de comportamento que é muito
distante da pessoa que você é.
Entenda, quando você, por exemplo, você
vai numa festa de família, você tem uma
persona, você tem um padrão de
comportamento, você tem um padrão de
comportamento que parece como se fosse
uma uma personagem e você tem você de
verdade, aquela pessoa que tá ali dentro
de casa.
Só que quando essa persona, todo mundo
tem essa persona, por exemplo, eu tenho
aqui, eu sou o Dr. Renan, eu tô aqui,
Dr. Renan, essa é minha persona aqui na
frente de vocês.
Só que existe o Renan, o Renan que é
filho, o Renan que tá com sua família,
existe o Renan. Só que se essa sua
persona se distancia muito de quem você
é de verdade,
gera um vazio muito grande,
porque você não se conecta com nenhuma
delas e você passa a não se sentir digna
de nenhuma delas.
Então, cuidado para você ter obrigação
de tentar assumir essa sentença, de
tentar ser alguma coisa que você não é,
que você assinou, talvez
lá na sua infância.
Então vai lá, faz por você, pô. Tira
essa roupa do guarda-roupa, veste a
roupa bonita que você quer, sabe? Faz
por você.
Porque se sentir digna é você entender
que
você tem que ser você mesma,
porque se você não for você mesma, você
vira um personagem
e nenhum personagem é tão digno quanto
você.
E lá no fundo você acha que não merece.
Você cuida de todo mundo, menos de você,
compra roupa pros outros, conquista algo
de bom e pensa: "Nossa, mas não vai
durar". Aí você sente uma fraude quando
te elogiam.
Seu corpo vira uma fatura de uma dívida
que não é sua.
Grava isso.
E você cria uma personagem que você
tenta proteger essa identidade e você
nem é essa pessoa. E aí no dia que você
se sente digna, o corpo para de punir,
acaba baixa baixa autoestima, você para
de se sentir não amada, tristeza,
a falta de alegria de viver é a raiz.
Então você tem a presa no invisível que
te domina e ele determina o sucesso
fracasso dessa jornada.
Entenda uma coisa, seu cérebro é uma
esponja
e ele vai absorver todos os padrões do
ambiente que você vive. E você vai viver
tentando achar um culpado, só que às
vezes é você que se culpa sem você
perceber por conta desses traumas que se
instalaram e você cria o medo. Então não
é falta de força de vontade.
Você tá numa restrição, resposta
estress, alteração, alterações
hormonais, aumento da fome, redução de
energia, abandono dieta, reganho de
peso, culpa do não merecimento. Você não
é digna e o ciclo se repete.
E eu quero te mostrar agora o que
acontece com uma mulher que quebra esse
ciclo de não sentir digna.
Olha essa história aqui de uma
nutricionista.
Sou do Rio Grande do Sul, gaúcha, tenho
60 anos feito agora em agosto, né? Sou
nutricionista, tô aposentada, sou da
área da saúde. Eu não trabalhei nunca na
minha profissão diretamente na parte
clínica, que era onde eu eu tinha, eu
gostava. Eu entrei muito na linha do
programa de alimentação do trabalhador
pelo PAT, todo um trabalho social,
envolvimento com a RT. Então, eh, foi um
trabalho que ficou sempre para depois. E
nesse depois eu esbarrava exatamente
naquelas dificuldades do efeito do ator,
inclusive para mim. E isso teve algum
momento da minha vida que me fez até
desacreditar da profissão. Eu digo, por
que que para alguns dá tão certo e para
outros não dá certo? Que que tem errado
nisso? E aí os sinais
Deus,
vamos falar em Deus, trouxe o senhor e o
senhor falou na base hormonal.
metabólica. E aí eu lhe respeitei muito
quando eu vi isso, porque eu ouvi que o
senhor tava falando da ciência,
não era mais um oportunista para se
valer da dor do gordinho, sabe?
Não era mais fórmula mágica, não era
mais eh não precisa fazer nada e o
resultado vem. E e durante essa jornada
toda, e é isso que eu quero dizer para
essas pessoas que estão aqui, as alunas
e as não alunas,
que o resultado realmente não é o
objetivo, como o senhor explicou,
o programa é que tem que ser levado a
sério, a jornada, porque tudo é feito
pensado
e sabe, eu me encantei por tudo. Eu
naveguei na sua plataforma, eu assisti
todas as aulas, eu participei de todas
as mentorias. Eu até hoje repito as sete
frases toda manhã e toda a noite me
olhando no espelho. Aliás, eu comentei
com a Salita
que
o momento de se olhar no espelho para
mim foi algo muito desafiador,
muito emocionante,
porque eu não sei quanto tempo eu não me
enxergava mais.
Então assim, o senhor trabalha o combo
da gente e e assim como eu era da área
da saúde, eu sempre soube jogar com a
parte técnica e não me perder de mim
mesma. Mas depois com eu tive que fazer
estereectomia, né? Eu retirei o útero
com 45 anos. Então, dali paraa frente
até o 55 eu fui me mantendo. Do 55 paraa
frente parece que tudo se perdeu.
E aí eu também não soube lidar com isso,
comigo. Eu acho que me abandonei,
esqueci de me olhar mesmo, esqueci de me
enxergar.
E quando eu descobri o senhor pela
Helena, a Helena investiu, eu na época
me dei a desculpa que não dava. Ah, tô
apertada, não tem como, não vou, não,
não vai dar. Aí o senhor vinha com os
bônus, com as promoções, com os
presentes. Ele dizia: "Não, numa
próxima, numa próxima". E aí Helena fez,
né, a turma antes da minha e quando ela
emagreceu os 25 kg em 45 dias, doutor
Renan, e eu falei com ela, porque ela é
uma amiga minha muito pessoal, eu tomei
um choque da realidade. Eu disse: "Deus
existe". [risadas]
[suspirando]
>> Eu nunca tive dúvida, né? Mas eu
brinquei assim porque ela era a prova
real, sabe? Ela era a prova viva daquilo
ali.
>> E e foi o o me olhar no espelho e me
emocionar como eu me emocionei foi a
certeza do quanto eu precisava me
resgatar. Eu disse hoje, se eu tivesse
que definir tudo que eu vivi até agora,
eu definiria a jornada com uma palavra.
É difícil, tá? Mas eu definiria como uma
palavra que é resgate.
Eu fui resgatada
por mim mesma, pelo Senhor, pela vida, a
vontade de viver, sabe? A disposição
para tudo isso.
É como se fosse magia.
Eu tô falando mesmo do coração. Eu tô
cuidando para não me emocionar.
Mas é emocionando, tá todo mundo é
demais, sabe? É impressionante a
transformação nisso. E assim, ó, eu
busquei o tempo inteiro saúde.
A estética incomoda muito, ela é a que
machuca porque ela tá ali. Mas quando eu
comecei, quando eu fiz os exames, que eu
vi que eu tava no limite do do da
diabetes, porque a minha resistência
insulina foi o meu maior problema. TSH,
bom, tranquilo, né? Mas o restante,
qualidade de sono, alimentação, Dr.
Renan, eu comia pão.
Pão, eu tinha preguiça de fazer almoço
para mim. Eu tomava um café com leite e
pãozinho,
nutricionista. Não me pergunte o que que
eu fiz com o meu diploma, tá? [risadas]
Não me pergunte. Mas assim, eu eu tava
tão sem propósito
que o senhor entrou e mexeu com tudo
isso. Foi um chacoalho mesmo, sabe? Uma
sensação de
de reencontrar Gisele que eu não sei em
que momento eu me perdi de mim mesma.
Foi sensacional.
Recomendo, pretendo, quando tiver
novamente voltar, porque eu vi que agora
tem a turma lavanda rosa.
Sejam lavanda, sejam tulipas, as, sejam
as flores que forem, mas vão paraa
frente, acreditem, porque o resultado
vem. Eu perdi assim, perdi, não,
eliminei, né, Dr. Renan, essa palavra é
melhor que é para não voltar, perder da
ideia que a gente pode ter de volta,
não, né? A [risadas] gente não quer de
volta. Mas eh nessa eliminação assim, eu
foram 14,700
g nos 45 dias.
E agora eu tô num momento pós PF que eu
tô seguindo o protocolo também a risca.
E aí eu consegui trazer mais esses
praticamente 3 kg e e 700, quase 4 kg
ali que cheguei nos 18 cravado.
É isso aí, Dr. Renato. Essa era a Gisele
antes e depois. Olha,
Gisele,
>> é uma imagem, Dr. Renan, para guardar,
pra gente ter certeza do quanto a gente
consegue, do quanto a gente pode e do
quanto a gente não precisa chegar nesse
estágio ali. Eu gosto muito de música,
sabe, Dr. Renan? Gosto muito de música.
E eu disse que eu não tenho vocação para
Raul Seixas. Eu não vou ficar sentada
esperando a morte chegar. Eu quero muito
é vida, muito vida. Agora sim eu estou
muito bem, porque agora eu estou
saudável. Hoje, Dr. Renan, a frase do
dia de hoje é eh eu celebro cada pequena
vitória no meu caminho para uma vida
mais saudável. É isso. É isso. A frase
do dia hoje é essa. E é o que eu tenho
feito, sabe? com muita gratidão, com
muito reconhecimento ao senhor e e com
essa mensagem para essas meninas todas
que estão aí, porque eu digo assim, ó,
mulherão é peito e bunda, né? Mulherão é
a gente ser mulher na essência. E é essa
mulher que eu fui buscar de volta. Eu
reencontrei a minha Gisele, então tô
firme e forte aí e sou muito grata,
muito grata mesmo.
Olha isso, né, gente? O reencontro, né?
Reencontro da mulher que você que você
é, que você merece. Mas a gente tem que
quebrar esses loopings mentais que vocês
estão. Porque assim como a Gisele, ó,
que perdeu ali 14 kg em 45 dias, depois
disso, 8 kg,
gordura abdominal,
baixa autoestima,
ah, vou me aceitar porque eu já tenho 60
anos. Assim, não é por aí. E eu te
pergunto, você se aceita? Porque lembra
o que que vocês confess confessaram pra
gente lá atrás?
Lembra daquela carta que vocês
escreveram?
Porque hoje a gente tem algumas coisas
pra gente começar a quebrar aquele esses
padrões de comportamento. Porque vocês
vivem nos loopings mentais, né? Um
padrão de pensamento repetitivo que você
não tem controle. Então são amarras
invisíveis que você não tem controle.
Você não se abandona porque você quer
isso. Você se abandona porque você não
percebeu que essa é identidade que você
criou sobre você. E a gente tem que
começar a quebrar essa identidade. E eu
te pergunto, quantas vezes você se
culpou? É uma libertação, né? Pera aí,
eu me culpo por muita coisa, mas pera
aí, eu não tenho culpa. Eu só tô
repetindo um padrão de comportamento.
Você sente vergonha, você acha que tem
alguma coisa errada com você e você tá
refém de um sistema invisível. E a gente
precisa se libertar desses padrões
tóxicos. E como que a gente começa a
libertar desses padrões tóxicos? Tira
print disso aqui, tá gente? Tira print.
Primeiro consciente para você começar a
se libertar disso. Quando você começa a
perceber os padrões, olha, tô fazendo
mais pelo outro aqui, eu me abandonei ou
tô descontando na comida, você vai criar
um alerta de autossabotagem.
O que que é esse alerta de
autossabotagem? Então, toda vez que você
perceber que você tá voltando para esse
padrão, que você não tá fazendo por
você, que você, opa, tô comendo
compulsivamente, tô saindo da dieta, tô
me abandonando, tô fazendo mais pelo
outro que para mim, opa, fui comprar uma
roupa para mim, mas na verdade falei
assim, não, acho que eu vou comprar pro
meu neto, vou comprar pro meu filho.
Você tem que começar agora a ter
consciência desses padrões. Então, você
vai criar um alerta de autossabotagem. O
que que é esse alerta?
O que você quiser. Por exemplo, meu
alerta de autossabotagem, eu vou na
cozinha e bebo dois copos de água.
Mas se você quiser, você pode passar
cada sua casa, na varanda e você pode ir
na no quintal e dar um grito. Ah,
entendeu? Um alerta. Eu preciso seja
qualquer coisa. Ah, grita, lê um um
pedaço de um livro, lê um lê uma página
da Bíblia, o que você quiser. Dá um
sacóde em você mesma. Vai lá, se olha no
espelho. Pera aí. Opa, quero me sabotar.
Deixa eu vir aqui na frente do espelho.
Se você sozinha, vai lá e se olha.
Alerta de autossabotagem.
Aí você começa a educar seu cérebro que
aquilo é errado e tudo que é errado o
seu cérebro tenta se afastar.
A gente engana o cérebro.
E o segundo nível de detox que eu
preciso que vocês tenham é a
reconstrução do eu. Eu quero que você
reescreva quem você é, porque hoje você
se acha uma mulher preguiçosa, que não
dá conta, que não é capaz, que não
consegue, que não merece, que é culpada,
que não é digna. É essa a identidade que
você tem sobre você. Essa é a persona
que você criou, é esse personagem que tá
aqui à frente da mulher que você é. E
como que você quebra isso? Como que você
quebra esse personagem?
Como que você quebra esse personagem?
Escreve. Hoje vocês têm uma tarefa.
Vocês vão escrever a mulher que você é.
Quando você escreve, você manifesta isso
na sua vida. Você ativa o tátil, o
visual e você lê. Você ativa o quê? A
fala. a audição, o cérebro, todos os
sentidos.
Todos os sentidos. Então você vai
escrever: "Eu sou digna, eu mereço. Eu
sou feliz. Eu vou fazer mais por mim. Eu
não, eu eu tenho disciplina, eu sou
focado, eu sou motivada, eu mereço ser
feliz". Você vai escrever tudo. Vai
escrever tudo que você quer ser, tudo
que você merece ser. Assim. E você tem
que ler essa página alguns dias para
você começar a introduzir que aquela é a
sua personalidade.
Aquela é a sua personalidade. Entendido?
E quantas vezes você precisa repetir um
padrão de comportamento para ficar mais
disciplinado ou aquilo virar um hábito?
No mínimo 21 dias. No mínimo.
E eu te pergunto, retirou a culpa das
costas? Se imagine hoje sem brigar com
seu corpo, sem fugir de espelho, sabe?
Isso é isso é uma delícia.
Só que você tá com essas amarras
invisíveis. E daí quando a gente cuida
de mente, base hormonal, metabólica e
ciclagem, dietas, o que que acontece?
Emagrecimento saudável, longevidade
saudável, prevenção de doenças, leveza
na vida,
tudo volta a acontecer.
Para você prevenir doenças,
para você viver mais, viver melhor, você
precisa do controle metabólico, você
precisa de alimentação saudável, mas
você precisa de uma mentalidade
construída para te deixar forte, para te
deixar blindada.
>> [roncando]
>> E a quinta chave secreta que eu vou
liberar hoje no final da aula, ela tem
relação com isso, com o seu plano
perfeito do emagrecimento. Hoje a quinta
chave secreta é o plano perfeito do seu
emagrecimento. E quem tiver aqui na aula
hoje no final, porque agora eu tenho
algumas coisas que eu vou montar o plano
perfeito na sua frente, quem tiver aqui,
esse é o bônus mais surreal de todos,
esse é para quem tiver, tá ao vivo na
aula, as 15 cartas do emagrecimento
definitivo.
Para todos os problemas que vocês
encontraram na sua saúde nessa semana,
eu escrevi uma carta para você, para
cada um desses problemas
e eu vou liberar no final da aula para
vocês.
Portanto, a gente não tá aqui só
construindo emagrecimento e quilos na
balança. Eu quero construir uma nova
relação com o seu corpo, uma nova versão
sua, a versão que você é de verdade. E
pra gente construir essa versão, agora
eu quero montar com você o plano
perfeito do seu emagrecimento
definitivo.
O que que é o plano perfeito do
emagrecimento definitivo? Primeiro,
lembra da casa que eu mostrei para
vocês? Pra gente construir um plano
perfeito do emagrecimento, eu preciso da
base sólida, base hormonal metabólica.
Sem cuidar disso não adianta. E como que
a gente, como que você trata da base
nessa, nesse plano perfeito? Um
rastreamento individual metabólico e
fórmulas naturais para corrigir cada
problema. Esse mapa do emagrecimento que
vocês preencheram, ele representa só 5%
de um rastreamento metabólico. Imagina
como análise completa da sua saúde, a
gente pega cada detalhe ali que você nem
imagina, assim como você não imaginava
dessa prisão dos três nós que vocês
estavam, que vocês estão ainda, da
culpa, do medo e da indignidade.
No segundo pilar da casa, alimentação.
Sem uma alimentação, sem ciclagens
dietas, não adianta. E aí para isso você
precisa de ciclagem dieta, dieta nova
toda semana para que seu metabolismo
mantenha ativo. E o terceiro pilar da
casa é o que a gente aprofundou hoje, a
mentalidade.
Porque existe um universo submerso no
seu inconsciente que você não conseguia
enxergar até hoje. Hoje você consegue
ter um pouco mais de consciência e visão
sobre isso. E você vai ter nesse plano
perfeito um método participativo,
tratamento dessa mente pra gente
construir uma mente magra de longo
prazo.
Então isso daqui é um plano perfeito do
emagrecimento,
alimentação, mentalidade, tratamento de
base hormonal metabólica.
Isso aqui eu chamo de um plano cinco
estrelas de emagrecimento. Se você até
hoje tentou emagrecer de alguma forma
diferente disso aqui, eu te digo,
é por causa de não ter feito dessa forma
que você viveu na efeito sanfona.
Só que agora eu quero te apresentar um
plano mais que perfeito, um plano 10
estrelas, que é outro nível de
tratamento e acompanhamento, que é o PEF
360,
meu programa de emagrecimento feminino,
360º.
E nesse plano mais que perfeito que é o
PF360, além do tratamento da base
metabólica com rastreamento, com
tratamento de fórmulas, você recebe a
minha análise completa.
Eu peço e analiso os seus exames,
eu te acompanho, eu sou seu médico, você
não precisa em outro médico para pegar
ali pedido de exames. Eu faço isso para
você. Você recebe devolutivo
individualizado depois de toda a análise
da sua base hormonetabólica. E se você
tem problema de tireoide, você vai
receber otimização da sua tireoide,
reposição de T4, T3. E vocês aprenderam
que tem o hipotiroidismo, toma remédio
tiroide por ano, levo cintroid, tiroóx,
tem que repor o T3 junto, mas seu
endócrino não sabe fazer isso por você,
porque ele está desatualizado. Não é
porque eu faço diferente, é uma questão
de atualização.
E se você tem um TSH de 2.3 para cima,
você talvez precise de microdose de T4 e
T3, porque o seu metabolismo pode estar
50% abaixo dentro da alimentação. Além
de toda a ciclagem de dietas, nesse
plano mais que perfeito que é o PF360,
vocês têm
aula sobre tudo sobre alimentação,
vocês têm consultoria de mercado, eu vou
no supermercado, é muito legal isso
aqui. Eu mostro produto a produto,
gente. Rótulo, eu te ensino a olhar
todos os produtos, escolher os melhores
produtos do supermercado. Eu vou na
farmácia, sabe? Farmácia de bairro. Eu
vou, vou na farmácia e mostro produto a
produto, [roncando] produtos bons de
farmácia que você encontra. Tem muita
coisa legal na farmácia, porque você
acha que só loja de suplementos tem
coisa legal, mas não. E aí eu vou também
em loja de suplementos e mostro produto
a produto para você. Você tem lista de
compras de mercado para você economizar
seu tempo, para você não ficar perdida.
tabela de substituição com mais de 200
alimentos, você não precisa ser privado
do que você gosta para emagrecer, gente.
O emagrecimento pode ser leve, pode ser
gostoso, prazeroso e você ainda tem
ajuda para montar o seu cardápio se você
tiver dificuldade.
Dentro da nossa mentalidade,
hoje vocês tiveram esse primeiro passo,
vocês têm aulas semanais com técnicas,
tarefas modifacionais para motivacionais
para você se tornar uma pessoa mais
focada, disciplinada, se libertando de
todas essas amarras.
sabendo lidar com sabotadores,
controlando ansiedade, dominando
compulsão, sintomas depressivos,
tentações. E tem um grupo Bom Dia
Meninas, onde eu coloco as pílulas
mentais todos os dias e tem lista de
fórmulas paraa pessoa que é mais
ansiosa, mais compulsiva, sem agredir o
seu organismo. Só que não para por aí.
Eu tenho um compromisso com o seu
resultado.
E temos os bônus do programa.
Temos aqui cinco bônus
de valor inestimável do PF360. Primeiro,
o acompanhamento médico comigo. Eu sou
seu médico. Eu tiro as suas dúvidas, eu
analiso seus exames, eu faço a sua
prescrição. E você tem acompanhamento
com o meu time de nutri. De segunda a
sexta, meu time de nutries, elas estão
disponíveis para vocês. E você tem a sua
ciclagem dieta desenhada e montada de
forma individualizada para você, porque
você é totalmente diferente da sua
colega. Você tem o seu tratamento
totalmente diferente, você tem a sua
ciclagem totalmente diferente, é tudo
individualizado e você ainda tem três
mentorias ao vivo comigo em grupo. São
três encontros que duram ali mais ou
menos um pouco mais de uma hora, onde eu
trago assuntos pertinentes daquela
semana e tiro suas dúvidas e você tem
acesso à minha lista de fórmulas com
mais de 20 fórmulas naturais para tratar
todo tipo de problema que vai muito além
de emagrecimento. O PEF 360, por mais
que ele se chame um programa de
emagrecimento feminino, ele não é um
programa só de emagrecimento feminino, é
um programa de medicina integrativa.
Para você que não quer perder peso, ele
é um programa de longevidade saudável.
Aí o time de nutrios vai montar
estratégia alimentar para você que não
quer perder peso, mas todo o tratamento
vai ser desenhado para você, para você
viver mais, viver melhor. Ainda tem um
módulo extra de interpretação de exames.
Eu te ensino a olhar os seus exames.
Você vai ser capaz de olhar os exames da
sua família. Ainda tem mais 11
protocolos de ouro pós PEF 360. Presta
atenção nisso daqui.
Isso aqui é independência pro resto da
vida.
Você tem protocolo para mais de 100
dias. Depois desse, você tem 60 dias
iniciais intensivos ali na pressão.
Depois mais 100 dias de ciclagem de
dietas desenhada para você ainda recebe
protocolo de dieta cetogênica. Isso aqui
é bônus. Protocolo de cetogênica,
protocolo de manutenção do peso,
protocolo de ativação do intestino,
protocolo de reativação do metabolismo
se você entrar no efeito platô, estagnar
no peso, protocolo completo de
suplementação, protocolo para quem tem
tá na menopausa, para quem tem lipedema,
para quem tem queda de cabelo, pele,
unha, protocolo paraa saúde do fígado e
protocolo pósfestas e feriados. Isso
aqui as alunas amam. Por quê? Você pode
ir para um feriado, sua féria, curtir,
sem se preocupar, curtir seu feriado com
sua família. Se fizer essa estratégia,
você pode comer o que você tá com
vontade lá, sem atrapalhar seu processo
de emagrecimento, sem te fazer ter
reganho de peso. As inscrições pro PF360
abrem na próxima segunda-feira, agora,
oficialmente 7 horas da manhã. Só que
tem mais uma coisa, eu sei que o
programa ele é muito completo, tem todo
o meu acompanhamento de todo o meu time,
tem bônus surreais, só que eu gosto de
além. Eu gosto de reconhecer as mulheres
que são comprometidas e as mulheres que
são hipercrometidas.
Quem são as comprometidas?
São as que vão entrar na segunda-feira
até às 23:45, ou seja, no primeiro dia
de inscrição. O que que as
hipercrometidas ganham? as hiper
comprometidas se inscreverem no primeiro
dia, ganham participação no sorteio de
10 consultas online comigo. Gente, eu
não atendo mais, eu não faço mais
consultas,
mas eu vou criar 10 horários na minha
agenda e para quem se inscrever no
primeiro dia, eu vou sortear 10
consultas online gratuitas comigo.
E tem as hipercrometidas. Quem são as
hipercrometidas?
são as que vão entrar primeiro
antes de todo mundo, ou seja, nas duas
primeiras horas de inscrição, ou seja,
segunda-feira entre 7 e 9 da manhã. E o
que que as hipercrometidas ganham? Bônus
exclusivo para as hipercrometidas.
Dois números para participar nos
sorteios das 10 consultas, ou seja,
chance em dobro. Você recebe duas
senhas. Quem se inscrever nas duas
primeiras horas, recebe duas senhas para
participar do sorteio das 10 consultas.
Você recebe também acesso ao guia
definitivo de dietas. O que que é esse
guia definitivo de dietas? É sequência
de dieta para várias situações da sua
vida. É independência.
São ciclagens de dietas para várias
situações e momentos da sua vida depois
do PEF e todas ganham participação
garantida na super consulta virtual
comigo. Fala Torana, mas quanto que vai
custar tudo isso? Eu preciso ser muito
transparente aqui com vocês. Por tudo
que eu entrego no PF360 e por ser um
programa com respaldo médico,
acompanhamento médico, nutricional
individualizado,
ele não é um programa barato.
R$ 20.000, R$ 1000,
que é o valor de pelo menos 10 consultas
comigo. Para você ter acesso a tudo que
eu entrego no PF360,
você teria que passar em pelo menos 10
consultas comigo. Quando eu atendia,
minha consulta era R$ 2.000.
Então, para você ter acesso a tudo
que eu entrego no PEF, você teria que
passar em pelo menos 10 consultas
comigo,
R$ 20.000.
Mas eu não vou te cobrar esse valor,
porque eu sei que ficaria inviável para
muitos aqui.
Antes de revelar o valor, eu quero que
você me responda algumas questões assim
de coração aberto mesmo. Quanto que te
custa hoje tá do jeito que você tá, né?
Você com dor no corpo, não tem energia
para brincar com filho, para brincar com
neto. Você se abandona. Você sente culpa
por cuidar de você. Você não sente
bonita quando você olha no espelho. Você
tá cheio de roupa num guarda-roupa que
não cabe em você, que você ou que até
serve, mas você não gosta. Você vai numa
loja e não tem a roupa que você quer do
tamanho
do seu tamanho. Você tem que comprar a
roupa que dá. Você vai tirar uma foto,
você tira foto só do rosto, você esconde
atrás de todo mundo,
baixa libido, tem que tomar um monte de
remédio hoje. Pressão de glicose para
dormir, ansiolítico, antidepressivo,
oscilação de humor, vive irritada,
ansiosa, o sono não é bom,
você não tá feliz, você tenta se
aceitar. Quanto que te custa
passar por tudo isso?
Algumas aqui eu vi alguém no chat
falando: "Nossa, me chamaram,
perguntaram se eu tava grávida". Gente,
olha o preço que vocês pagam.
Sua saúde não vale R$ 20.000?
Pensa, reflete sobre isso.
Eu espero que você entenda que você vale
muito mais do que isso,
porque você precisa começar a enxergar o
seu valor. E eu te ensinei isso nessa
aula.
e vendo o estado de saúde de vocês no
desafio e tudo que vocês me contaram de
pontuação, um perfil hormonal que vocês
estão,
o custo do não investimento em vocês
hoje vai ser muito maior lá na frente.
Então vou trazer algumas coisas aqui, só
para vocês terem noção. Lá na frente, se
você tiver artrose, você vai passar a
gastar pelo menos R$ 200 por mês.
Alteração de coluna, por conta de peso,
mais de R$ 400 por mês. Alzheimer,
demência, doenças neurodegenerativas,
remédio pode chegar a R$ 1.000 por mês,
sem contar remédio de pressão, remédio
de colesterol, remédio de glicose,
ansiolítico, antidepressivo, remédio
para dormir.
O tempo tá passando, então a hora é aqui
e agora.
Saúde não espera, gente. Não dá para
deixar para depois, não dá para
procrastinar.
E cuidado que a procrastinação tá muito
ligada àquele medo que a gente conversou
hoje.
Eu não vou te cobrar R$ 20.000.
Então pensei em cobrar metade disso. R$
10.000.
Só que eu vou melhorar essa oferta para
você. Se você for uma das 30 primeiras
inscritas, escuta isso que eu vou falar.
Se você for uma das 30 primeiras mais
rápidas, você vai receber o meu kit
secreto na sua casa. E o que que tem
nesse kit secreto para as mais rápidas?
Primeiro, caneca do PEF 360 paraas 30
primeiras entregue em casa. O planner do
PEF 360, que é esse nosso planejador,
onde você tem todo organizador de rotina
com uma apostila, com um conteúdo muito
incrível dentro.
Todas que se inscrevem no primeiro dia
recebem o e-planner para você poder
imprimir. As 30 primeiras recebem ele
físico em casa. E o item surpresa três
do nosso do meu kit, as 30 primeiras
recebem em casa a pílula do pãozinho,
que é aquela fórmula que a gente vai
sortear no domingo, que é uma fórmula
desenvolvida por mim, que atrapalha a
absorção de uma refeição livre.
E o item surpresa quatro desse kit,
pílula seca a barriga. É uma fórmula
termogênica natural, qualquer pessoa
pode utilizar, que ela atua em gordura
localizada. E junto com essa fórmula,
você recebe acesso a um protocolo seca a
barriga para seguir depois do PEF 360,
onde o objetivo é a gordura localizada.
E as 30 primeiras também vão receber em
casa.
E todas que se inscreverem no primeiro
dia, ou seja, segunda-feira até às
23:59, vão ter acesso à receita da
pílula do pãozinho e do seca barriga e
também acesso ao protocolo seca a
barriga.
Você fala assim: "Tor Renan, mas se
antes já achava que ia ser caro, imagina
com esse monte de bônus, todo esse
acompanhamento, todas as estratégias,
tudo que tem no programa. Quanto que vai
custar tudo isso? Calma,
não vai ser R$ 20.000.
E também não será R$ 10.000,
R$ 4.000
ou em até 12 de 400. Eu sentei com a
minha equipe, falei assim: "Olha, nada
mais justo a gente entregar tudo que tem
no programa, todo o acompanhamento, todo
resultado que as alunas vão ter e
independência pra vida cobrando o valor
de duas consultas. Quando eu atendia,
minha consulta era R$ 2.000. Então, pelo
valor de duas consultas comigo, você tem
acesso a tudo isso.
Só que eu tenho uma boa notícia para
você.
Não vai ser R$ 4.000
e nem 12 de 400.
O valor do investimento é de apenas 12
de 219,70
sem juros.
12 de 219,70
Só que eu preparei mais uma surpresa
aqui para você.
Aliás, duas surpresas.
Primeiro, a caixa secreta. Tá vendo essa
caixa aqui, ó? Essas caixas aqui. As
três primeiras mais rápidas que se
inscreverem vão receber a caixa secreta
em casa. E dentro dessa caixa secreta
tem em média R$ 2.000 em produtos
surpresas.
E as cinco primeiras
inscritas mais rápidas ganham consulta
gratuita comigo garantida. E uma última
coisa,
não será 12 de 21970.
Na aula de ontem, eu prometi que eu ia
fazer algo diferenciado para você que tá
participando do desafio pelo seu
comprometimento comigo
nessa semana.
Porque você se priorizou, você que
chegou aqui comigo até o final da
semana,
eu tinha te prometido isso.
Paraas comprometidas que se inscreverem
no primeiro dia, ou seja, segunda-feira
até às 23:59,
vocês terão um desconto adicional.
Preparadas?
E o valor do PEF 360 para vocês nessa
oportunidade
será de
12 de 159,70
100 juros. Somente nessa oportunidade
essas condições não irão se repetir.
Então de 12 de 219,70
por 12 de 159,70
100 juros.
Isso aqui dá 5:30 por dia. Com 5:30 por
dia, você não compra nenhum cafezinho
com pão na chapa na padaria.
Mas é uma escolha e você
pode entrar no PEF 360.
Essa é uma condição especial dessa
turma. Não irá se repetir com todas
essas condições, com todos esses bônus,
principalmente esse valor especial.
E temos todas as formas de pagamento.
Cartão de crédito à vista. Cartão de
crédito tem até 12 vezes sem juros.
Qualquer cartão. Você pode usar mais de
um cartão. Parte no Pix à vista, parte
no cartão. Se você mora fora do Brasil,
você consegue entrar de qualquer lugar
do planeta. Se você quiser boleto e
transferência bancária, fala com uma
equipe no WhatsApp. Quando chegar o link
de inscrição na segunda-feira, vai ter
um botão verde que você consegue falar
com a minha equipe no WhatsApp. E aí
essa modalidade de boleto e
transferência bancária, você precisa
chamar nossa equipe e falar: "Olha, eu
quero no boleto, quero transferência
bancária". E aí nossa equipe no WhatsApp
gera para você essa condição. Você tem
acesso ao PEF 360, acesso à plataforma e
as atualizações que forem sendo feitas
pelo período de 1 ano. Só que você pode
fazer um upgrade pelo um valor simbólico
quando você clica aqui no ato da
inscrição pelo pelo tempo de 2 anos.
Mas é a única oportunidade que você tem
de fazer isso aqui, tá? Depois não tem
como a gente acrescentar.
E quando você fizer sua inscrição, vai
aparecer um presente para você. Esse
aqui eu não posso revelar o que que é
aqui, que somente quem se inscrever, a
hora que seu pagamento for confirmado,
vai aparecer um vídeo meu com
presentaço. Não fecha essa página. Se
você fechar a página, você perde o
presente. Então, pega o presente depois
que você fizer sua inscrição.
Recapitulando tudo aqui, as três
primeiras vão receber a caixa secreta em
casa com até R$ 2.000 em produtos
surpresas. As cinco primeiras ganha
consulta gratuita comigo. As 30
primeiras recebe meu kit em casa com píl
do pãozinho, pílo seca barriga, caneca,
planner, protocolo seca barriga e as
inscritas nas primeiras horas ou seja,
as hipercrometidas que se inscreverem
nas duas primeiras horas. Bônus para
participar dos dois dois números para
participar do sorteio das 10 consultas.
Acesso ao guia definitivo de dietas,
participação garantida na super consulta
virtual. Receita de todas as fórmulas
que eu passo em lives, fórmulas extras.
Vocês recebem
praticamente, é assim, é muito
tratamento para várias questões que vão
além de emagrecimento, que são bônus
para quem inscrever nas duas primeiras
horas. E as inscritas no primeiro dia
até às 23:59 recebem um desconto de
primeiro dia, participação no sorteio
das 10 vagas de consulta online comigo,
receita da pílula do pãozinho e pílula
seca barriga para você mandar manipular
onde você quiser e acesso ao meu
protocolo seca barriga material com
aulas. Como que vai funcionar? Presta
atenção que essa parte é muito
importante. Segunda-feira, 7 horas da
manhã abrem as inscrições oficialmente.
Você vai receber o link que te dá acesso
à página de descrição. Ele vai ser
enviado no seu e-mail. Grupo VIP,
WhatsApp do Desafio, no meu Instagram,
todos os canais, 7 horas da manhã,
todas as minhas redes. Só que tem uma
forma de você receber o link 30 minutos
mais cedo, ou seja, 6:30 da manhã. Isso
aumenta as suas chances de ser uma das
primeiras inscritas e também de garantir
sua vaga.
Como que você recebe o link 30 minutos
mais cedo antes de todo mundo? No meu
canal do Telegram. O que que é Telegram?
Telegram é igual WhatsApp, só que tem
esse simbolozinho aqui, ó, azulzinho,
desse aviãozinho, igual WhatsApp. Só que
o Telegram, qual que qual que eu vou
mandar o link 30 minutos mais cedo lá?
Porque grupo de WhatsApp, vocês sabem
como é que funciona. Grupo de WhatsApp
ele tem um limite de pessoas. Então eu
tive que criar vários grupos, centenas
de grupos de WhatsApp e eu não consigo
com um clique fazer o link chegar no
mesmo segundo para todo mundo, porque o
WhatsApp ele vai disparando pouco a
pouco, senão ele trava. E como nós temos
prêmios para as primeiras inscritas, eu
preciso te dar a oportunidade de receber
o link junto com todo mundo. Eu preciso
ser justo nisso com você. E o e-mail, eu
tenho mais de 1.700.000
1000 e-mails cadastrados deste evento,
de eventos anteriores. Então, o e-mail
eu não consigo com um clique fazer com
que todo mundo chegue, que o link chegue
ao mesmo tempo para todo mundo. Ele vai
disparando pouco a pouco, o sistema
dispara pouco a pouco. O único lugar que
eu consigo fazer isso e ser justo com
todas vocês é no meu canal do Telegram,
porque no Telegram é um grupo só meu,
onde um clique todas vocês recebem o
link no mesmo segundo, ou seja, 6:30 da
manhã. Se você puder escolher um único
aplicativo para ter no seu celular na
segunda-feira, que seja o Telegram. Ele
é gratuito, tá gente? Ele é gratuito.
A minha equipe vai enviar aqui no chat o
link do Telegram e eu também vou colocar
na bio do meu do meu Instagram. O que
que é bio do Instagram? Deixa eu mostrar
para vocês, ó. É isso aqui, ó. Então,
quando você vai no meu Instagram, eu vou
colocar aqui no chat. No final da aula
eu vou colocar aqui agora, mas no final
da aula eu vou colocar de novo para
vocês entrarem. Mas quando você vai
aqui, ó, no meu perfil do Instagram, tem
esse link aqui, ó. Se você clicar nesse
link, vai aparecer aqui embaixo, a gente
vai deixar disponível para vocês aqui
embaixo o acesso ao canal do Telegram.
Equipe, depois eh coloca o link lá do
Telegram pra gente no no Instagram, tá
bom? Vai ficar aqui para vocês também,
mas entrem no canal do Telegram, isso
aumenta as suas chances de ser uma das
primeiras inscritas.
>> [roncando]
>> Ah, Dan, mas será que vai funcionar para
mim? Tô na dúvida.
Para isso, eu quero tirar o peso das
suas costas, o peso da sua decisão. Você
tem 14 dias, incondicional. O Código de
Defesa do Consumidor te dá 7 dias. Você
pode cancelar qualquer compra que você
quiser no período de 7 dias. Eu te dou o
dobro disso. 14 dias. Entra,
experimenta. Você achou que não é para
você, só pedir dinheiro de volta. Claro
que eu não quero que você entre pensando
em desistir, eu quero que você entre com
vontade.
E temos uma segunda garantia. Vamos
supor que você fez tudo e você não teve
resultado. Essa é uma garantia
condicional. Vou ver se você fez tudo
mesmo. Você tá com você desenhar
estratégia. Se você não tiver resultado,
eu devolvo seu dinheiro mais R$ 500 pelo
seu tempo perdido.
Só faz esse tipo de garantia quem
garante a qualidade do trabalho que
entrega. Mas eu quero que você entre com
vontade de fazer.
E se você mora fora do Brasil, não se
preocupe. A nossa plataforma mais segura
do mercado é Hotmart. Você consegue
entrar de qualquer lugar do planeta.
Se você tiver qualquer problema com a
Hotmart, pode ser que a minha equipe no
WhatsApp te mande uma segunda plataforma
que reduz, mas aí é só se você tiver
problema com a Hotmart. E aí minha
equipe vai te dar essa segunda opção no
WhatsApp. Caso você tenha qualquer
dúvida, qualquer [limpando a garganta]
questão, quando chegar o link de
inscrição na segunda-feira tem um botão
verde que você consegue chamar a nossa
equipe no WhatsApp.
Entendido? Então confie. Eu vou deixar
depois uma postagem no Instagram, os
números oficiais aí, confie só nos
números que estão lá. Mas se você clicar
no link de descrição que foi liberado
nos canais oficiais e no botão verde,
você pode confiar. O acesso à plataforma
do PEF 360 você recebe imediatamente
assim que seu e-mail, assim que seu
pagamento for aprovado, você vai receber
no seu e-mail e a gente também vai te
chamando no WhatsApp depois.
Caso você tenha
alguma dúvida, então não se esqueçam,
chama a nossa equipe no WhatsApp na
segunda-feira, no link de descrição, mas
eu tenho um pedido para te fazer. Se
você está interessada, seja rápida na
segunda-feira. Por que que eu digo isso?
As vagas do PEF são verdadeiramente
limitadas.
Isso que eu tô falando para vocês é uma
verdade, não é papo, tá gente? Elas são
limitadas, porque eu por mais que eu
tenha um time grande, eu sou seu único
médico ali. E eu não consigo fazer um
acompanhamento de um número tão grande
de pessoas de forma individualizada.
Por exemplo, olha os números do nosso
evento, milhares de visualizações,
milhares de participantes. Eu não
consigo nem perto, nem perto acompanhar
esse número de pessoas. Portanto,
coloquea despertador na segunda-feira,
entre no canal do Telegram, 30 minutos
mais cedo será liberado o link lá, ou
seja, 6:30 da manhã, na segunda-feira.
E eu digo isso por se ainda tivermos
vagas às 7 horas da manhã, quando eu
liberar o link no meu perfil do
Instagram com mais de 9 milhões e meio
de seguidores,
meu canal do YouTube com mais de 1.8
milhão,
as vagas se esgotam rapidamente.
Por isso eu te peço, se você está
interessada, seja rápida, avisa no seu
banco, liga no banco, fala assim: "Olha,
segunda-feira eu vou fazer a compra no
valor tal, porque isso aumenta suas
chances. você não está acostumado a
fazer esse tipo de compra numa
segunda-feira de manhã. Pode ser que seu
cartão bloquee por segurança. Então,
avisa. Tudo isso aumenta suas chances de
garantir sua vaga. E outra coisa, quando
eu liberar aqui para vocês a nossa lista
de presença, manifeste, vai ter um campo
nesse nossa lista de presença de hoje
para você manifestar o seu interesse.
Então, manifesta o seu interesse,
preencha esse campo de super interessada
em entrar no PEF 360. Com isso, eu vou
deixar minha equipe de suporte, as
alunas para te atender e te receber com
toda prioridade, ok? Manifeste o seu
interesse na lista de presença hoje. A
lista de presença está no chat.
E meninas, temos o sorteio. O sorteio
que vai acontecer na última aula,
lembra? Sorteio. O que que é o sorteio?
Ó, hoje a gente ainda tem a nossa quinto
bônus das 15 cartas.
Domingo vai acontecer sorteio ao vivo.
Quem que participa? Quem preencheu todas
as listas de presença. E como que vai
funcionar? Você vai vir aqui ao vivo e
aí só quem tiver ao vivo consegue
receber. É a aula mais especial de
todas. Pílula do pãozinho, fitoterápico
para energia e gelzinho dos sonhos para
libido feminina. Sorteio vai acontecer
na nossa sétima aula.
E temos o concurso. Deixa eu falar sobre
o concurso aqui para vocês. O concurso
ele vai ser liberado na aula de amanhã
e você vai ter até, eu coloco aqui até
às 20 horas, mas eu gostaria que vocês
preenchessem um concurso amanhã. Quem
for participar, quero que todas vocês
participem
até às 2as da tarde pra gente ter calma
e analisar cada uma das histórias. vai
concorrer quem preencher todas as listas
de presença. Você tem que cumprir eh o
formulariozinho que eu vou mandar
amanhã, porque só quem preencher aquele
formulário eu vou saber que você quer
participar do concurso, que você merece,
que você vai me contar tudo bonitinho.
Amanhã eu vou te explicar todos os
detalhes e vocês vão se pesar amanhã. Eu
quero que vocês amanhã, se for possível,
acorde, pese,
pese, tira a foto de depois. Foto de
antes, e depois. OK. Foto de antes,
depois. Tem a foto de depois.
E prêmio. Qual o prêmio da ganhadora do
concurso?
Análise individualizada do mapa do
emagrecimento dela feita por mim.
Vai receber o kit de suplementos pílodo
do pãozinho, fitoterápico para
energiasinho dos sonhos e ela ganha uma
vaga garantida no PEF 360
dessa nova turma que começa na
segunda-feira. Então, vale muito a pena
você participar do nosso concurso. E
temos as chaves. A quinta chave secreta
de hoje é o quê? O plano perfeito do seu
emagrecimento definitivo. Então, temos
aqui o plano perfeito do emagrecimento
definitivo. Essa é a nossa quinta chave.
Tudo que você precisa saber sobre esse
plano perfeito pro seu emagrecimento
definitivo, mais lista básica de exames
nesse material. Só que esse material,
liberei para vocês, ele tem uma senha.
Como que você abre esse material?
Qual a senha? Eu magra 2026. Tudo junto,
tudo maiúsculo.
Então, qual a senha? Qual a senha,
meninas? Eu Magra 2026. Tudo junto, tudo
maiúsculo.
OK. Eu Magra 2026.
Tudo junto, tudo maiúsculo.
E quem tiver na aula ganha esse bônus.
Esse é um dos bônus mais especiais.
15 cartas do emagrecimento definitivo.
Quando você preencher a sua lista de
presença, você vai receber esse nosso
bônus extra. as 15 cartas do
emagrecimento definitivo. E o que que
são essas 15 cartas? Lembra, meninas?
Ó, lembra, meninas, que eu falei para
vocês que cada aula eu libero um bônus
para quem tá ao vivo? Quando você
preenche a lista de presença, você vai
poder baixar as nossas 15 cartas. Lembra
que você escreveu aquela carta para você
daqui a 7 dias? Agora sou eu que escrevo
15 cartas para você. Como que vai
funcionar? Então você vai vir aqui, como
que você encontra suas cartas?
Você [roncando] tem que, passo um,
encontre as cartas que combinam com
você. Aí o passo dois, você vai achar o
número da carta. E depois você vai rolar
esse material para baixo e vai ler os
números das cartas [limpando a garganta]
que foram indicadas para você. É o
seguinte, você pode ter várias, se você
tiver muitos problemas de saúde, pode
ser que você tenha que ler várias
cartas. Então aqui, ó, nós temos todas
essas cartas aqui. Deixa eu mostrar para
vocês.
Então, nós temos todas essas cartas.
Nós temos todas essas cartas aqui. Carta
para quem é sentinela, refém,
sobrecarregada, prisioneira, para quem
tem problema tireoide, gordura no
fígado, intestino, cortisol, sono de
macalidade, insulina alta. E as cartas
aqui para situações, você que já tentou
de tudo, você que come pouco e não
emagrece, você que teve o seu corpo
mudou depois dos 40, você que tem o
metabolismo travado, você que tá com
baixa autoestima, não tem força, não tem
ânimo. Então olha só, você vai descobrir
embaixo da cartinha tem um número e
quando você rola para baixo aqui,
você vai ter o quê? As cartas com dicas
sobre esses problemas. Cada uma das
cartas com dicas sobre esses problemas.
É um material muito lindo que a gente
fez com muito carinho para vocês aqui,
que são bônus especiais que nós nem
tínhamos prometido para vocês, mas como
eu digo, a gente sempre vai entregar
muito mais do que a gente promete, que a
gente tem prazer em surpreender vocês.
A gente tem prazer surpreender vocês.
Então [roncando] agora você tem dois
caminhos, tá? Você tem dois caminhos.
Um caminho que você tem, você pode pegar
esse plano perfeito e levar em algum
médico para tentar te tratar, para
tentar seguir esse plano, mas
dificilmente ele vai fazer porque não
sabe fazer. Não é fácil fazer esse nível
de tratamento e acompanhamento, porque
você passa em uma hora de consulta, ele
vai te passar uma dieta profissional,
não vai te passar 14, 15, 16, 20 dietas,
não vai te passar.
Então você pode seguir sozinha com tudo
que você sabe, com tudo que você já
cometeu de erro, com as dietas antigas
que você tem, mas você já sabe o
caminho. Você pode continuar nesse
caminho, reclamando, colocando a culpa
no outro, sendo ingrata,
culpada, com medo.
E aí aquela frustração vem da da forma
de não se sentir digna.
Porque às vezes você se coloca numa
posição de vítima onde todo mundo tem
que fazer tudo por você. Assim, ó,
estender um tapete vermelho para você.
Só que você não valoriza o trabalho de
ninguém. Só que você também que tá na
posição da vítima, você culpa sempre o
outro. E quando a vítima culpa o outro,
você aprendeu uma coisa hoje. A
responsabilidade passa a ser do outro e
não sua. Aí é muito fácil viver. Você
pode seguir esse caminho, mas tem um
segundo caminho. E nesse segundo caminho
é eu sendo seu médico, eu do seu lado,
com todo o meu time, pegando na sua mão,
te apoiando em todas as etapas e
dificuldades que você tiver. E o
trabalho que a gente desenvolve é um
trabalho muito sério, é um trabalho
verdadeiramente digno da sua confiança,
onde você vai ter análise de seus
exames, eu peço seus exames, ciclagem
dieta individualizada, todo
acompanhamento e você consegue nos
próximos 45 dias emagrecer até 20 kg,
cuidando da causa [limpando a garganta]
raiz do problema, mudando a sua
mentalidade, mudando o seu padrão de
comportamento.
Mas isso tem que partir, essa mudança de
comportamento, não adianta só ter força
de vontade. a gente tem que instalar
estratégias para quebra de padrões. E eu
espero que você escolha segundo caminho
do meu lado na segunda-feira no PEF 360.
Eu sei que é muita coisa incrível essa
semana. todas as aulas, todos os
materiais, toda a entrega, todos os
bônus, todas as chaves secretas, toda a
nossa plataforma, todo o conteúdo e todo
conhecimento sobre você e claro, toda a
nossa estratégia de jejum, porque eu
quero que vocês se pesem amanhã,
porque agora você aprendeu se amar, se
valorizar, se enxergar,
porque hoje nós temos o post do desafio,
que é
[roncando]
esse daqui. Aqui, ó, eu Magra 2026. Eu
vou fazer esse post lá no meu perfil do
Instagram. Eu quero que você vai lá e
coloca #eumagra2026.
Eu quero que você manifeste isso na sua
vida, que você não só vai ficar magro,
mas mais saudável. E coloca o que você
se conectou relacionado à mentalidade
dessa aula. Eu, Magra, 2026, coloca lá,
porque eu não vou ter mais culpa. Eu vou
me priorizar, eu vou me amar, eu vou me
perdoar, eu vou me sentir merecedora.
E coloca o que que tem valor aqui para
você, o por que você vai ser magro em
2026. Qual o divisor de águas que foi de
conhecimento nessa semana?
Estão desafiadas porque esses posts
contam pontinhos. E amanhã, gente, a
nossa aula, amanhã tem aula, tá? Sábado
tem aula.
Aula sobre exames. Eu quero todo mundo
com exames em mãos. Eu vou ensinar você
a olhar os seus exames e eu vou falar
sobre suplementos. Amanhã a aula é
[roncando] surreal. Amanhã, meninas,
temos a aula completa de suplementação.
Aula completa de suplementação e temos
aula completa de exames.
Entendido, gente? Tudo sobre exames e
suplementação amanhã.
Amanhã, OK. Quero todo mundo aqui comigo
amanhã 7 horas ao vivo, sabadão,
viu meninas?
OK.
Amanhã na nossa aula seis, então, o que
que nós temos? Tudo sobre exames,
suplementos emagrecedores, liberação do
concurso. Vou liberar o concurso amanhã
para vocês, o sexto bônus ao vivo e a
sexta chave secreta. Só falando uma
coisa, quem não conseguiu entrar no
no Inst, no Telegram,
você pode vir aqui, ó,
vai no meu perfil do Instagram, você
clica no link na bio aqui, clica no link
na bio. Quando você clica no link na
bio, vai o primeiro item, acessa o canal
do Telegram e você consegue entrar no
canal do Telegram aqui também. Perfeito.
OK. Vocês têm acesso a toda a plataforma
do PEF pelo período de um ano, viu,
meninas? Mas, ó, muito obrigado todo
mundo pela presença aqui hoje. Vejo
vocês amanhã, que é uma das aulas mais
incríveis, porque a gente fala de exames
e suplementação, ok, meninas? Um beijo,
vejo vocês amanhã. Tchau.
Anos. Eu sou do Rio de Janeiro. É,
então, na verdade, eu sou maquiadora
profissional, mas eu também sou
professora. Não estava me sentindo bem
comigo mesma. Eu acho que ninguém, sendo
sincera, ninguém se sente bem com 130
kg. Eu tava com quase 130, eu tava com
125 kg, então eu não tava me sentindo
bem. Eu, maquiadora profissional não
tava me maquiando, por exemplo. Então,
isso para mim era o auge. Como uma
maquiadora profissional, que sempre teve
um sonho de ser maquiadora profissional,
eh, não conseguia se maquiar. Eu não
conseguia me sentir bonita, minha pele
não era bonita, nada meu, assim, eu me
olhava no espelho e não me reconhecia. E
hoje, por incrível que pareça, fazendo
essa live, eu tô olhando pro espelho
exatamente agora. Eu não consigo não me
olhar no espelho. É o tempo inteiro. Eu
no começo até o fim foram 20. Agora, até
agora são 25 kg.
tava sentindo uma angústia de est há
muitos anos, há 16 anos, eu tava lutando
contra a balança, mas essas tentativas
eram muito frustradas, né? Eu fui em
tudo que vocês podem imaginar e utilizei
tudo que vocês podem imaginar também.
Nutricionista com dieta de gaveta,
endocrinologistas, eu e eu já tava quase
entrando nos 100 kg, eu tava com 98.2,
eu tenho 1,71. E aquilo tava se eu não
tinha roupa que eu conseguia usar, mas é
porque eu não queria mais uma vez me
frustrar. E eu falo isso e eu mexe
comigo porque foram muitos anos me
frustrando, muito, muito, muito. Eu
eliminei, eu tava com 98,2, eu eliminei
11 kg. Já tenho um total de 19 kg
eliminados. Aí quando eu falei que eu ia
fazer o jejum, o marido até falou: "Mas
você quer emagrecer mais?"
tava descompensada. Eu dormia muito, o
meu problema, eu dormia muito, mas
acordava super cansada. Parecia que eu
não tinha dormido nada. Na hora do
almoço, no meu serviço, eu encostava a
cabeça, eu dormia. Insulina, cortisol,
intestino também. E eu já tinha tentado
várias tentativa de emagrecimento, tomei
remédio para emagrecer, aqueles
controlad,
mas depois montava tudo de novo. 45 foi
11,500.
Hoje é 17,
100. 100. A gente só acredita eu fazendo
as montagens que eu vi. Tamanha
diferença. Não, não imaginava chegar ao
que eu estou hoje.
Sou Luzeni, tenho 54 [música] anos. Eh,
moro em Goiânia, Goiás. E eu já tinha
assim, eu já tinha tentado feito muitas
[música] tentativas para emagrecer e eu
já antes do meu 50 anos era mais fácil,
era um pouquinho mais fácil, né? fazia
uma dieta, fazia um exercício físico e
aqueles [música] que vinho eu conseguia.
Depois tudo foi ficando mais difícil,
doutor, depois dos 50 anos e a barriga
crescendo,
só aumentando o peso, principalmente
barriga, né? Eu estava bem desacreditada
de de conseguir emagrecer. [música] 45
dias eu já tinha emagrecido mais de 10
kg. Acho que eu, porque eh minha meta
era 10 kg, né, doutor, eu emagreci 14,
né? E eu mantenho isso. Eu fiz eh já tem
uns meses e eu mantenho. E eu hoje em
dia eu fujo da dieta. Eu às vezes eu
final de semana eu como doce. Eu assim
eu fujo da dieta e eu não ganho [música]
peso. At tá mantendo.
>> Eu sou Roxana e eu moro no Paraguai. Eu
me formei no no Brasil [música] em
dermatologia. Eu sou dermatologista e h
minha luta eu tentando lembrar agora
enquanto eu assisti a aula começou desde
que eu era menina. Tenho essa
dificuldade que ten alguma dificuldade
eu vou comer. Tô bem, eu vou comer.
Então [música] era era uma coisa assim
uma luta de toda a vida, né? Como eu
acredito muito na medicina funcional e
eu já comecei a tratar os meus meus
pequenos pacientes com acne, já falando,
você tem que dormir bem, você tem que
fazer exercício, você tem que comer
muita verdura, essas coisas. E eu não
podia ser o exemplo aí, né? Porque eles
me olhavam e eles falavam: "Mas ela que
tá fazendo, né?" Então eu sentia isso
cada vez que eu falava para eles, né?
Então eu falei, eu tenho que ser assim
com um exemplo, eu tenho que arrastar
com um exemplo, não com as palavras. Nos
primeiros eh 45 dias, mas aquelas duas
semanas, eu emagreci 13,400.
Depois, eh, quando a menina falou para
mim falar, eu tava com 18 kg a menos.
Essa mesma roupa
para ver como que ficou. Depois, agora
tô depois do detox. Eu tô com 24,900
kg a [música] menos.
>> Eliminados. Olha isso, Rotsando.
>> Meu nome é Raimunda, eu tenho 46 anos,
né? Eu me descompensei,
eu perdi a vontade de tudo, de fazer
tudo. Aí acabou que eu fui ganhando
peso, fui ganhando peso. Quando eu
percebi, eu já tava muito acima do peso.
Aí chegou um dia que eu me assustei
[música] quando eu me olhei no espelho.
Falei: "Não, eu preciso fazer alguma
coisa, porque eu não sou assim. Como que
eu me deixei chegar a esse ponto? Eu
consegui perder
>> 17 kg,
>> eu acho que quase uns 17 kg para você
ver. Eu acho que depois você vai mostrar
a foto pras meninas. Aí vocês vão ver
que eu
>> Ol, olha a diferença [música] das
costas.
เ